could even jump breck it even to you
let's start first of all with dr. Ronnie
Jackson to hear the White House tell it
Democrats were out to destroy the career
of a good man the Democrats say the
president should have known better than
to send the Menominee that would never
be confirmed the upshot of all this dr.
Ronnie Jackson is withdrawing his name
from consideration and the president is
now looking for a new nominee to be VA
secretary signing autographs for
children on take your kids to work day
President Trump today I'm loaded on
critics who forced Veterans Affairs
nominee dr. Ronnie Jackson to withdraw
he's a great man in a statement
dr. Jackson denied the laundry list of
allegations Democrats had amassed
against him saying I expected tough
questions about how to best care for our
veterans but I did not expect to have to
dignify baseless and anonymous attacks
on my character and integrity the Senate
Minority Leader said if anyone is to
blame for the Maelstrom around dr.
Jackson its president Trump the
president is what caused this problem by
not properly vetting by making these
decisions on the fly by making sure they
don't count as the Jackson withdrawal
was still settling the president's
embattled EPA Administrator was in the
hot seat in Congress bombarded with
questions about political favors and
excessive spending on travel security
and a secure phone booth she were unfit
to hold public office and undeserving of
the public trust Pruitt insisted the
charges against him are way overblown
half-truths or at best stories they've
been so twisted they did not resemble
reality perhaps one of the most
controversial issues facing Pruitt huge
raises that were given to two epa
staffers against the direction of the
White House in a Fox News interview
Pruett denied any knowledge of the
raises or who would prove them so who
did it maybe there would be some
accountability of career person or
political person I don't know I don't
know you don't know who didn't but
Pruitt admitted today he gave his chief
of staff the authority to grant pay
increases he knew the two staffers
wanted raises however Pruitt says he
didn't know the details one of the ace
who received a substantial raise stated
that you
were aware of and supported the races
was that true I think with respect to
races what's more yet with that truth
it's not aware of the amount nor was I
aware that the bypassing or the PPO
process not being respected in a morning
phone interview with Fox and Friends
President Trump today put the Department
of Justice on notice start investigating
charges level that his opponents he said
or he might just step in I have decided
that I won't be involved I may change my
mind at some point because what's going
on is a disgrace it's an absolute
disgrace and after denying any knowledge
of the stormy Daniels payoff for the
first time today President Trump
appeared to acknowledge Michael Cohen
was working on his behalf he represents
me like with this crazy stormy Daniels
deal he represented me and you know from
what I see he did absolutely nothing
wrong
and a new development today in the case
of Rob Porter the former staff secretary
here at the White House who was fired
back in February in the letter to
chairman trey Gowdy the FBI says that it
first sent over derogatory information
about Rob Porter on March third of 2017
that derogatory information file was
addressed Don Magan the White House
counsel's office but the White House
continues to insist it did not learn
about the allegations that Porter abused
his two ex-wives until February 6th of
this year that's nearly a year later
White House officials tell Fox News that
McGann never saw that file but no one
could explain why right John it was
clearly a bumpy ride for Scott Pruett up
on Capitol Hill is there a sense behind
the scenes there that his future has
changed in the eyes of the White House I
don't know if this changes things any
great to any greater degree than they
were already at Brett I mean it's no
secret around here at the White House
that the only person in this building
who supports Scott Pruett is the
president but then again he's the only
person who needs to and last thing on
Ronnie Jackson he goes back to his
former job as he gonna stay there you
know that's that's a question he's
currently working in the White House
medical unit but when he was tabbed from
the nomination for VA secretary he
ceased being
the president's personal physician and
now they're wrestling with this idea of
could he'd go back to that position with
this cloud of allegations hanging over
him but then again if he says that none
of it was true and it wasn't true why
should that prevent him from going back
but at this point nobody has launched an
investigation to try to clear all this
up so his future right now
Brett remains very much in limbo John
Roberts Slaven North Lawn John thank you